michael clearly not too much has changed
overall with the red shading over the
last week or so uh when we're zoomed out
but if we zoom in now specifically to
kiev we'll see there's quite a lot going
down beneath the surface including some
successful counter-attacks by the
ukrainians here around kiev yes indeed i
mean as we see there the the ukrainians
seem to or they claim to have
created some successful counter-attacks
at urpin a buco near there hostimel the
very important airfield whether or not
they've got the airfield the russians
certainly aren't using it so they're
achieving their objective and by and
large the ukrainians are getting in
behind the russians at certain points
along the perimeter making it very hard
for the russians to continue their
encirclement of kiev which was obviously
their strategic objective and we heard
the announcement today that russia's
going to reduce its focus on kiev it
sounds like that might not be something
completely of their own choice uh i
suspect it's a rationalization of the
military situation they now find
themselves in let's now go from kiev
down to the east then the southeast of
ukraine and have a look at what's uh
going on here in the week ahead what
will be russia's main objective in this
region yeah so things are happening
which don't seem connected but they're
very connected
the ukrainians have conducted a pretty
big counter-attack
trust your nets
and that is an important crossroads
between the city of sumi and kharkiv and
also across roads to poltava further
south and the point is the ukrainians
are trying to prevent the russians
finishing off kharkiv that's really
important the russians want to finish
off there they want to finish off at
mario paul to redeploy their troops
meanwhile that's vera donetsk which is
the the new capital of the luhansk
region uh because the the ukrainians
have got to work from somewhere they're
fighting very hard around there again to
stop the russians reorganizing their
troops what the russians want to do is
to draw a line from kharkiv down to
mario paul to to push southwards to push
northwards and insulate isolate the
ukrainian troops who are the wrong side
of that line and so what what forces
does the ukrainians have in this area
will they be able to easily repel the
russians there what are the choices
there for them well they've got 10
brigades which is about 50 000 troops
and they are the best of the ukrainian
army so it's about a third of the
ukrainian army is in that area um and if
they are encircled they either have to
choose to fight the encirclement or
maybe withdraw give up the the fight as
it were in the east in order to live
another day and perhaps defend kiev in
the weeks to come and so even if the
russians are successful in taking this
region which again is just zoomed in on
only the southeast of the nation i guess
it's all relative because even odessa in
this region is a long way from the red
shaded area so it's it's a kind of
reduced objective of the russians for
sure
the russians were clearly pushing
westwards to odessa that was a big
strategic objective in order to landlock
ukraine to actually cut off all of their
access to the sea
they are further away from odessa now
than they were because mikolayev has
held and they've been pushed back east
from nikolayev so that looks as if it's
a big strategic objective which has gone
in obeyance while the russians think
about a much more as a big but minor
objective of trying to encircle
ukrainian forces in the east defence and
security analyst michael clark as always
thanks so much uh that's the latest for
now